الوقت يداهم مرشح المعارضه كمال كلتشار
اوغلو اقل من اسبوع يفصلوا عن جوله
الاعاده والضلوع بلحظه نصر ماموله على
اردوغان هذا الاسبوع في عدو فرصته الاخيره
لكسب مزيد من الاصوات والقيام ببعض
التغييرات في استراتيجيه حمله الانتخابيه
الاستراتيجيه تغيرت بالفعل والمعارضه لجات
للورقه الاخيره اي القوميه التركيه راميه
خلفها وعود الربيع والعوده الهادئه
للديمقراطيه واظن سياسته الجديده لتوسيع
نطاق المنتخبين لصالحه ومن ضمنهم انصار
سنن اوغن سيركز كلتشتار اوغلو على وعوده
بطرد ملايين المهاجرين اذا فاز
بالانتخابات ورقه القوميه يلعبها
السياسيون الاتراك بالعاده عند حاجتهم
لرؤيه نتائج سريعه لكنها تنطوي على مخاطر
ومجاسفات كما تقول صحيفه
اذا تعد انحرافا كبيرا نحو اليمين واشاره
الى الياس الذي بلغه مرشح المعارضه القناه
نائبا سابق في حزب الشعب الجمهوري لفت الى
حاجه كلتش الى تقديم صوره لقائد هادئ
وقادر وثابت لضمان تصويت الكثير من الناس
كما يخاطر كلتشتار اوغلو بصد الناخبين
الاكراد اليساريين الذين دعموه باغلبيه
ساحقه وازعاج مؤيدين ليبراليين في المدن
الكبرى مثل اسطنبول وانقره لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات